let's continue our discussion about
Donald Trump and voting and vote by mail
Republicans are not even pretending to
hide their desire to suppress turnout in
November why Republicans no lower
turnout is better for them it's it you
know sometimes we have to get into the
weeds and explain this that they just
know it's better for them for fewer
people to vote Donald Trump also by the
way vote-by-mail creates a paper trail
which they don't want it makes it more
difficult to disenfranchise
people they don't want any of this stuff
right Donald Trump has been ranting and
raving against vote-by-mail for more
than a month snap month now in the last
week we've seen this full-court press
from him and from his press secretary
and from others Donald Trump threatening
to withhold money from states if they do
vote by mail as I already told you
Michigan and Nevada and now Donald Trump
used this word honor again when talking
about suppressing votes
you might remember earlier this week
Donald Trump said it was an honor to
have the most coronavirus cases in the
world that was really weird here is
video of Trump again arguing against
vote by mail saying voting is an honor
now in reality voting is a right but
let's take a listen to what Trump said
common sense we tell you that its
massive manipulation can take place
massive they and you do you have cases
of fraudulent ballots where they
actually print them and they give them
to people to sign maybe the same person
signs them with different writing
different pens I don't know as a lot of
things can happen now if you can you
should go and vote voting is an honor it
shouldn't be something where they send
you a pile of stuff and you send it back
voting is an honor it shouldn't be
something where they send you a pile of
stuff Donald Trump says they send you a
ballot the same ballot you would get at
the ballot box and they send you an
envelope in which you return that ballot
it's not a pile of stuff now what's
fascinating is that what Trump is
describing is is number one a terrible
way to win an election and number two
it's something that it's exclusively
Republicans who have been caught doing
it so there's the retail oh sorry I hit
my mic there there's the retail strategy
of voter fraud and then there's the
wholesale strategy of voters
crashing and election fraud so the
retail strategy is what Trump is talking
about you you know vote-by-mail is a way
that people could send into ballots or
you know you vote harvesting or whatever
the case may be terrible way to win
elections and it also doesn't happen
seven to eight instances of vote by mail
fraud per year
statistically zero the whole sales
strategy is you suppress the vote you
buy election officials you reduce
turnout that is actually the simpler and
more effective way of stealing elections
so the entire strategy Trump is
describing here you know duplicates and
printing ballots and all of this
different stuff it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen 250 million absentee
ballots have been cast over the last 20
years and we have seven to eight
instances of so-called fraud with those
per year Trump again though talking
about fake ballots and the light take a
look well I think if we're talking about
the mail-in ballots if people mail-in
ballots is a lot of illegalities they
send in ballots that
they harvest ballots you know all about
harvesting and they do lots of bad
things ideally people go out and they
vote now if you need a mail-in ballot if
you need a specific like as an example
I'm in the White House and I have to
send the ballot to Florida that makes
sense so if you need it for some reason
or if somebody's not well that's one
thing but when you send out 7.7 million
men mail-in ballots
there's forgeries there's frankly
duplication where they print ballots or
the same kind of paper with the same
kind of machinery and you can't tell the
difference and they send in thousands
and thousands of fake ballots and I tell
you what this nation can't be going down
that path because it's a very dangerous
path to go down this is not a dangerous
path to go down it's a very advanced and
sophisticated path to go down ballot
harvesting which Trump talks about that
something Republicans have been caught
doing and other than a couple of
instances of Republicans doing it we
don't know of any ballot harvesting that
turned any
I believe there was a special election
kind of think there was one district in
2018 I don't remember if it was a
special I think it was North Carolina I
wish I had it in front of me where this
sort of funny business from a Republican
strategist likely influenced the results
or it could have there are really no
other examples of it now on the other
hand the strategies that the right uses
like voter suppression closing down
voting places purging people from voter
rolls that is how you actually suppress
the vote in order to win elections you
know double votes in person voter fraud
absentee ballot fraud doesn't win you
elections now let's talk about the
bigger picture just a little bit not
much good is likely to come from
coronavirus we can hope right we can
hope this will be a wake up call will
realize how fragile our economic systems
are and we will strengthen them we will
make them anti fragile to take a phrase
from Nasim Nassim Nicholas Taleb we
might realize that we were totally
unprepared for a pandemic we'll get
better prepared for the next pandemic I
don't know that that's really going to
happen
Trump disbanded the pandemic response
team from shouldn't have we didn't shut
things down quickly enough
March 5th would have been a perfectly
reasonable time to do it didn't happen
South Korea did it Taiwan did it New
Zealand did it there's a lot to learn I
don't know that we're gonna learn
anything there if we can move a bunch of
states to vote by mail it would be a
major advancement and maybe we can make
some progress there but this entire
voting is an honor thing don't be
tricked voting is a right period this
entire voting is an honor and it should
be done the way Trump likes its publicly
justifying voter suppression
specifically to get Donald Trump
re-elected Trump sees the polls Trump
publicly says Joe Biden has no shot but
we know Trump is scared
Trump two weeks ago furiously got on the
phone with his campaign manager Brad
parse kale and said how the hell am I
losing to Joe Biden Michigan could be
key for Donald Trump he's threatening
Michigan about vote-by-mail they are
doing it in broad daylight they have to
be stopped and one of the ways that we
stopped them is by ensuring that
everybody votes in
November if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just fifteen minutes and you get all
of the important core ideas and
information from that book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do or if you
just want to sample a book before you
buy the entire thing I recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great Stephen Hawking this is a book
that I have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video